voilà un jour martin son assistante
m'appelle et me dit écoute christophe
son chauffeur est tombé malade il faut
que tu le remplace je dis bah écoute pas
tout si moi j'étais content je distribue
le courrier donc je me dis c'est cool je
vais de chauffeur de jean luc delarue
donc j'étais jeune j'avais une vingtaine
d'années et puis elle me dit écoute
voilà je tire à le récupérer demain
matin à 9h parce qu'elle a rendez vous à
10h avec jérôme seydoux chez pathé et le
rendez-vous ne peut pas le rater c'est
le patron de pathé un jour de chez pathé
et du coup ça me donne l'adresse tout ça
et où elle me dit c'est pas chez lui il
est si hubert boukobza en fait dans un
hôtel particulier dans le 16e et donc du
coup j'arrive avec la voiture là bas je
sonne
ça me répond en personne ne me répond et
tout et puis au bout de cinq minutes un
portail s'ouvre là je me retrouve dans
une maison incroyable moi j'ai jamais vu
ça de ma vie r je commence possible une
maison aussi grand n'est qu'un jardin
plein plein plein coeur de paris et où
et puis je rentre dans cette maison et
puis là je vois que ma famille une
grosse fête qui a été fait
et là vous voyez d'année le mot
[Applaudissements]
avec un string
donc et en fait j'ai un costume dans les
mains et c'est la maison est grande donc
je venais où est ce que je vais pouvoir
trouver jean luc et là il ya une
demoiselle qui sort d'une caisse judy
s'cusez moi c'est pas que je peux
retrouver ceux de la rue amedi chambre
rouge tuant rouge chambre rouge
moi je commence à monter à l'étagé là
pour change ou une porte rouge donc je
commence à frapper et où personne ne me
répond j'appelle assistant dédié à
martin écoute je suis derrière une porte
elle est rouge et costumes qu'est ce que
je fais à dire entre
jeu j'ouvre la porte et là effectivement
je vois jean du qui dormait depuis
qu'est ce que je fais un petit réveil le
clash média temps moi je suis arrivé
chez réservoir prod ya six mois je suis
avec un costume dans les mains je dois
rêver jean luc delarue je suis dit mais
j'étais sûr oui oui aucun jeu mais je
m'approche de lui je commence un petit
peu à le secouer gentiment et où je
m'aperçois que l'on adore bien quoi et
je suis dit je fais quoi me dise coup le
jeu commence à le secouer n'avait pas
fait comme moi comme quand je rêvais
et
du coup se réveille
incroyable donc là il m'appelle par tous
les prénoms sauf par par le mien je dis
que jean luc tu te poses ton costume sur
le lit je t'attends en bas quoi qu'il
arrive au bout de dix minutes par en
voiture et non pas la voiture il me dit
pas un mot et tout en parle donc je
dépose je dépose chez pathé et là je me
plante c'est à dire que au lieu de
déposer à l'entrée principale des
postures ne portent pas me dérober tout
aimé du coup très ce mois là et on se
voit tout à l'heure chez réservoir prod
est là je me dis moi c'est fini pour moi
forcément je les guide dans un état que
j'aurais pas dû
et là je me dis bah tu sais quoi c'est
dans une belle voiture qui l'a je prends
tout mon temps pour rentrer un réservoir
prod ce que là j'ai fais pas je suis à
la deauville
et du coup j'arrive à un réservoir et et
il lui arrive de trois heures après et
me convoque dans son bureau et il me dit
écoute christophe voilà qu'est ce que tu
aimerais faire chez moi et je distribue
le courrier et je lui dis qutb avoir une
tête des ambitions et tout type ba ouai
je dis on va bien travailler au public
clair le public c ap les gens pour
qu'ils viennent tout sur le plateau est
tout et mehdi ben écoute tu commence
demain matin en fait ça a été un an
chinois comme ça deux choses et c'est
pour ça que je voulais aussi le
remercier parce bien sûr c'est un garçon
quatre cas qui donnait qui donnait sa
chance aux jeunes enfin moi je suis
arrivé nulle part c'est pas un milieu
que je connaissais pas et finalement
j'ai réussi à non avec voilà jean luc
épicé équipe autour de gravier gestion
et puis
benjamin bailly il a quand même raté je
pense que le plus gros contrat de sa vie
avec tf1 puisqu'il devait de signer au
mip si tu connaissais tu sens c'est le
grand salon 2
joe biden est en fait il y avait une
fête la veille encore une fête est
arrivé au petit déjeuner le matin
doublement dans un état un peu normal un
peu fatigué il est parti avec le buffet
du petit déjeuner donc ça s'est su
qu'ils n'étaient pas forcément en forme
et l'avion de boeing était en train de
deux femmes étaient partis pour aller
signer le contrat avec à l'époque le
directeur finances cost et edouard
boccon-gibod août a connu qui est en
fait on le l'information est revenue aux
oreilles de le lait que visiblement
l'animateur qu'il allait engager pour un
énorme contrat avait une grosse tendance
à prendre des produits stupéfiants et
comme l'est et le président tfc comme et
comme et comme patrick le lay monsieur
le lay avait vécu un drame personnel à
cause de la drogue par rapport à ses
enfants pour lui il a droit que c'était
rédhibitoire il a fait faire demi-tour à
l'avion et le contrat s'est jamais signé
tout ça parce que david avait fait mais
je pense qu'il veut voir mal à il avait
pas de limites il s'en foutait existe
lors milliard d'âmes est donc plus gros
que la vie à l'excès est toujours plus
loin toujours plus fort human life by
adobuzz c'est un peu comme bigger than
life bigger than life outils comme
biyouna life
rigueur oui patron de français il était
très riche ou pas jean moulin non
honnêtement non c'est comparativement à
d'autres n'ont franchement pas
on va pas se mentir non mais il a en
fait et georges jean luc a fait des très
mauvaises affaires des restaurants il a
englouti près de 50 millions sa société
était devenu une espèce d'énorme boîte
où il y avait près de 600 collaborateurs
qui étaient ni ce redressement
judiciaire ils ont dû faire un plan
externe qu'il a perdu encore beaucoup
d'argent il a laissé me dont on parle de
22 millions c'est ça dès lors un
appartement sur les quais de paris il ya
eu des maisons à beni douala l'île de ré
il ya les amarres fois qui a été vendu
au groupe lagardère pour 10 millions
d'euros je crois à l'époque donc c'est
passé c'est beaucoup d'argent mais
comptant sur steam mais comparativement
à ce qu il a à ce qu'il a brassé ce
qu'il a générée c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup moins que beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup d'autres d'accord voilà
même le terme allah il ait pas de bateau
n'est pas de 4,4
[Applaudissements]
christophe c'est vrai que c'était un
c'était une vie incroyable un joli
boulot parce qu'aujourd'hui jean luc
delarue sais c'est quoi c'est un peu lol
est l'équivalent en quoi c'est une amie
ces voix là aujourd'hui c'est quoi ces
c'est vrai ces annonces et annoncé ça
serait plus vous
moi je ne bois que de l'eau à quelques
noms mais c'est vrai qu'on n'en
resterait que on n'a pas du tout le même
fonctionnement c'est vrai qu'il ya pas
mal de gens qui m'ont dit plein de fois
aussi je vous jure que c'est vrai qu'ils
m'ont dit c'est vrai que tu nous fait
penser à jean luc delarue ben oui oui
mais c'est vrai que j'ai jamais moi
j'adorais jean luc tu manges tu es fan
absolu mais c'est vrai que moi on n'a
pas du tout le même fonctionnement moi
c'est vrai que je suis je suis
naturellement agitée en fait
c'est à dire que la différence trop de
jean luc delarue moi c'est que jean-luc
il arrivait à l'antenne il se transforme
et moi c'est vrai que je suis le même
sur le plateau on ne l'était pas agiter
en fait maintiendra paradoxalement il
était pâle et plutôt abrutis et sommet
est assommée par tous qui prenait en
alcool et la vérité c'est que jean luc
delarue avant même de commencer à fabre
était vraiment une star était déjà dans
une addiction à l'alcool et aux
médicaments donc en fait c'était énorme
réussite qu'il a eu comme tu l'as dit
n'a fait que l'amplifier une fin qui
était qui était déjà bien bien présente
mais ce qui est moi je le trouve assez
étonnant c'est que 1 et ça vous l'avez
pas tellement des dents voeckler dock
mais ce qui est dommage pour lui c'est
qu'il était beaucoup protégé et que si
on n'avait pas autant protégé dans une
époque peut-être qu'il aurait pu arrêter
ses commandes
il ya eu beaucoup de de son affaire
voilà qu'ils ont et son entourage et son
entourage n'étaient pas forcément le
meilleur